[Applause]
thank you very much thank you thank you
[Applause]
thank you for thank you for letting a
sinner in your midst Michael Eric Dyson
will be out here shortly to take me to
take me to the woodshed but first there
is someone who works weeks and me Donald
Trump if you watch the Comey testimony
piece people actually went to bars and
restaurants at 10:00 in the morning to
watch this [ __ ] I mean it's all part of
the campaign the Republicans have to
make America day drunk again so just to
give you a quick recap the former
director of the FBI said on five times
during the testimony that the president
lied to him demanded his loyalty above
his honesty threatened his job wanted to
shut down the investigation when that
didn't happen fired him and the
Republicans still will not impeach him
if only Trump had asked called me to
blow him
[Applause]
but what we're so shocking to people is
that Trump did not tweet for 46 hours
that's a new record how about it for
president but of course it couldn't say
where Furman today it wouldn't despite
so many full statements and lies total
and complete vindication and Wow
cold me what a leaker hoodie but then he
wrote a hashtag still Putin's [ __ ] you
know America is a funny place it all
comes down to who you believe a
pathological liar who has been known to
interrupt himself mid lie to tell
another lie God for the patriotic Boy
Scout who took meticulous notes every
meeting he took notes right after Trump
needs more meetings where people take
notes they're called psychiatrist
but listen and his Comey was contacted
he said nine times night time he's only
bit off is like a hundred days by Trump
many of those times Trump asked everyone
else to leave the room to the point
where Comey had to tell other people
don't leave me don't leave me along with
him to which every Trump beauty pageant
contestant said welcome to our world
[Applause]
here's the part I love
[Applause]
call me testimony he says Trump said to
him I have been very loyal to you very
loyal we had that thing when is
everything Trump say sounds like a wire
top of the Gambino's we had that thing
in the clam bar you know the piano wire
that thing we did Trump probably has a
mob name for call me Jimmy tooth all
remember when he had him come over to
him at this Jimmy to call c'mere you
remain man now
someday I may need a favor and that day
may never come take the gun
leave the cannoli you know it but the
last person to question call me
yesterday oh my gosh john mccain did you
say this I mean look I've had mixed
feelings like all of us have write about
John McCain for years but he's been
pretty good on this lately we thought he
was my hope I've said here a nation
turns its lonely eyes to you and I
thought oh this is going to be McCain's
finest hour
the maverick the Lion of the Senate is
going to put country before party and
stand up to Trump's [ __ ] and then
out comes mr. Magoo
[Applause]
it's
[Applause]
no one no one knew who this man was
talking about at one point the closed
caption for the hearing-impaired just
went no clue he spoke for seven minutes
the last five were all about who's been
messing with the thermostat I mean with
that you know that's just age catching
up for somebody what's Paul Ryan's
excuse Paul Ryan said yesterday if you
know if comi came out with the same
testimony about a Democratic president
we wouldn't be going for impeachment Oh
for [ __ ] sake if this was Hillary with
the same [ __ ] going on they would have
yanked her out of office so fast
the only thing would be left would be a
smoldering pantsuit
and then he said he said trunk didn't
mean to obstruct justice he's just new
at this yeah right until now he's been
lying in the private sector he's just
new in what other profession can you get
away with this bear with me I'm not a
dentist I work at a shoe store
and it's not just a missus where we are
ladies and gentlemen the main Republican
talking point is essentially Trump is
too stupid to be guilty of anything but
what if that's the case is any too
stupid to be President
[Applause]